[Music]
in December 2018 for the first time
teacher strikes and snare to charter
school network this was seen by many as
another sign that unions are coming for
charter schools
indeed unions have worked avidly to
organize more charter school teachers
are they succeeding nope during the past
decade the share of unionized charters
is actually declined what's the story
well it's tough for unions to organize
charter teachers when union leaders are
busy treating charter schools as a
political pinata and at Target during
teacher strikes and legislative fights
it's also not clear that unions think
charters are often that Lea worth the
trouble
charter schools tend to be small account
for just a tiny fraction of all teachers
and typically require unions to work
school by school rather than by
organizing whole school districts at a
time charters have much to offer
teachers frustrated by district
bureaucracies but this has been too
rarely celebrated or communicated by
advocates whatever the unions do that's
one place charters need to do much
better do you think it's good or bad for
charter schools to be unionized let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI